it's been seven months since i spent
what i thought was way too much money on
the airpods max
but now that i have a ton of experience
actually flying with them
using them to edit videos listen to
music watch movies
and now that we've had multiple firmware
updates are these
still worth spending the money on or
have my thoughts
changed i'm gonna try to keep this
long-term update video short but still
cover a ton of topics
such as durability battery life the
active noise cancellation performance
different software changes and overall
give you a nice
long-term review of these headphones
let's start out with durability how have
they held up over this time span
the top headband here no issues it looks
just like new
the ear cushions they do have a couple
bends in them from
you know being shaped around my ears but
as far as softness and wear there's
really nothing and the thing that i was
most concerned about
is both of these cuffs banging each
other they still look
like new which is fantastic the headband
as far as the tension for the adjustment
it is just as good as new as well so
overall durability wise these things
have held up extremely well
battery life wise i did have a few
issues but thankfully those have been
solved thanks to
firmware updates i would just have drain
overnight that was much worse than i was
expecting
and then i would have to plug it in to
charge so apple actually addressed that
with
one set of firmware and now it's a lot
better and i end up not even using this
little soft case i just leave it on my
desk
and i throw these into my bag and then
with that
there's actually been another update
that apple didn't mention what it was at
all
but to me going into active noise
cancellation
i think it's made it even better i flew
with it
and it's just crazy how much it blocks
out the extra sound that is there it's
almost like you're not in the airplane
it's definitely a cut above what sony
offers
with their over ear headphones i've also
used these on a few road trips it worked
excellent and then even
mowing the lawn these things block out
an insane amount
of sound so if you're looking for a
great active noise cancellation
it has only gotten better compared to
like the airpods pro
which most people agree that's gotten
worse with algorithm changes i'm not
sure if that's for battery life or what
but these things are killing it with
that i'm still shocked by how well the
microphones
work and how well the transparency mode
works
nobody can even tell that i'm using a
pair of bluetooth headphones it sounds
just like my iphone and i've actually
started using these with the
transparency mode just in my office
i'll have some music turned on quietly
and it sounds like i'm not even wearing
headphones i hear the environment
perfectly so vadim or angelica talk to
me
then i'm able to hear them but then also
the benefit is throwing into
active noise cancellation mode and
turning up music and then just drowning
everybody out and being able to just
focus on what you're doing
so that also works really well and now i
want to talk about
what has impressed me the most and why
i'm basically just shocked with these
how well they sound
even more so than when they first came
out i'm enjoying these even more
but first if you're somebody that
appreciates long-term reviews
and longevity talking about that kind of
stuff hit that subscribe button down
below and with that you can help us
reach our goal
of a million subscribers before the end
of the year i would greatly appreciate
it
and that is the latest updates to apple
music
and spatial audio and dolby atmos
i have to tell you guys i went and i
signed up for apple music
again i left apple music a couple years
ago for spotify
the difference is noticeable now i know
people say
that hey even airpods max they don't
support completely
lossless or uncompressed music that's a
bummer you're spending so much money
but the sound quality difference between
spotify's best quality
and lossless on apple going through
bluetooth
is ma it's so noticeable with these
headphones it's incredible
you've definitely noticed one it's
louder that's because these headphones
don't have to automatically turn down
the volume to limit
uh distortion and to the clarity
especially in the high end vocals as
well but the high end it's night and day
when you flip back between spotify and
apple music
you notice and even if you don't flip it
back you hear some of the songs that you
love
they sound fantastic so lossless it's
not a gimmick
it's a free upgrade for those that have
apple music and it makes these sound
fantastic now
another level to this is dolby atmos
when i heard dolby ammo so my command
virtual uh surround sound in headphones
i had dolby almost in my theater
speakers above you that sound fantastic
but headphones really
but when i heard it especially this song
from skrillex
my goodness it sounds so good with atmos
you have two different levels to it the
first one is just having sound all
around
and having giving artists the ability or
those that are doing mixing
to play certain sounds anywhere all
around you
is awesome and the extra separation that
you get sounds incredible
these already have a really good sound
stage for a sealed headphone
but going from say mono where sound is
one to stereo you get a wider sound
to be able to have a rounder sound and
then doing atmos where you have above
it is awesome you hear the separation
you get a wider sound stage between
certain instruments and vocals
and it sounds fantastic and you can get
sounds not just on one side and moving
but literally sounds all around twisting
around you
it sounds fantastic and apple even will
allow
spatial audio to work with songs that
aren't coded for dolby atmos and
in that case in some cases it actually
does make music sound better especially
newer tracks
but the downside is with that or even
dolby atmos with some older songs
for example move along by the
all-american rejects that sounds
terrible and that's actually coded into
dolby ammo so don't expect
if you buy these headphones everything
to sound great if they just drop the
track into dolby atmos
in its older track it's kind of like
dropping an sdr video into an hdr
timeline and thinking it's going to make
it sound better
it could actually make it worse so in
this case you get some more clarity
but vocals sound distant and very low
some instruments don't sound good and
it's the regular stereo mix
is much better but songs that are
properly tuned for atmos
where you give the artists more control
about about where they want certain
interests to be
in separation it sounds incredible if
you saw
sdr video compared to hdr it's a similar
thing but for
audio now there's also the aspect of
head tracking where it feels like you're
in a concert
you have all these instruments all
around you you're twisting your head and
the direction is staying where it should
be that part is cool
um in video as well but it's kind of
like a novelty to me
now the next thing as far as sound
quality movies same thing dobby ammos it
is just
insane and these headphones for 550
or even as low as 400 bucks for the
lowest price i've seen refurbished
you can't beat it with the home a home
theater system you just cannot
because they go down to 25 hertz even
down to 20 hertz as far as base
and it just rumbles your head it is
crazy and then the separation of
different sounds
and having animals all around and above
you it just gives you the best audio
experience for movies
at that price point of course it's only
for you it's not like a home theater set
but for a home theater system to get
this level of audio
you have to spend probably about five
grand which is what i put into my
previous ammos and even then the
separation and
where different sounds were wasn't as
good as this
and i don't know if my system went down
to 20 hertz i don't think it did
probably about 35 but still you really
get a lot of value
for what you're spending then of course
integrating into ios so
i'm not going to focus on those things i
already talked about that in my full
detailed one month review none of that
has really changed
but that has been the update to the
airpods max so
am i happy that i kept them i did that
review two days before my return period
ended when i had to send them back i
definitely am the sound quality is
phenomenal active noise cancellation is
even better
certain bugs have been worked out and
overall
it's hard to beat this even though it's
expensive if you buy this or buy
buy a pair from apple and test them out
i think you'll be
very happy so thank you guys for
watching click that circle above if you
guys want to subscribe
for more videos like this one check out
my other videos right over there there's
been max and i'll see you
in the next one